une histoire du français film signé
Cathy Lena India et documentaire qui
porte une thèse assez claire celle d'une
monnaie qui serait le symbole d'une
décolonisation pas complètement achevée
et donc d'une domination pas
complètement terminée tout le monde
n'est peut-être pas d'accord avec cela
parlons-en tranquillement avec nos
invités Victoria Lurel bienvenue vous
êtes sénateur socialiste de la
Guadeloupe vous êtes le co-auteur avec
la sénatrice Nathalie Goulet d'un
rapport d'informations sur la zone franc
fait au nom de la commission des
finances du Sénat Nicolas normand
bienvenue à vous également vous êtes
ancien ambassadeur de France au Mali en
République du Congo et au Sénégal et
vous êtes l'auteur aux éditions Eyrolles
du grand livre de l'Afrique réédité en
juin dernier Bruno Cabriac bienvenue à
vous également vous êtes directeur
général adjoint des études et des
relations internationales à la Banque de
France ancien chef du service de la zone
franc et du financement du développement
ancien conseiller financier pour
l'Afrique à la direction générale du
Trésor hamzat Boukhari yabara bienvenue
à vous également vous êtes historien et
auteur notamment de une histoire du
panafricanisme publié aux éditions La
Découverte merci à tous les quatre
d'être ici avant de réagir à la thèse du
documentaire et pour que les bases
soient très claires je voudrais que l'on
regarde une carte avec les pays qui
utilisent aujourd'hui le franc CFA vous
allez me dire si elle est juste
d'ailleurs une quinzaine de pays au
total allant du Sénégal à la République
du Congo en passant par la Côte d'Ivoire
le Bénin le Cameroun le Gabon sans
oublier car on oublie parfois les
Comores des États qui sont soit membres
de l'Union économique et monétaire ouest
africaine soit de la communauté
économique et monétaire de l'Afrique
centrale est-ce que c'est bien ça Bruno
Cabrillac est-ce que je ne dis pas
d'erreur est-ce qu'on peut faire une
petite minute de pédagogie pour que tout
soit clair pour noter les spectateurs et
bien c'est vrai que ces pays utilisent
des monnaies qui sont reliées par la
France par une convention monétaire mais
ce sont pas des pays qui utilisent le
franc CFA ce sont des pays qui utilisent
les Français F1 et le franc comorien et
là on voit bien une am réalité puisqu'on
parle aujourd'hui du franc CFA en
réalité ce n'est pas le français enfin
il y a deux francs CFA qui sont deux
monnaies deux zones différentes qui sont
gérées par des institutions différentes
d'un côté la Béa que et la Commission de
la CM d'autres côtés la BCEAO et la
Commission de l'UA et qui n'ont si je
puis dire rien à voir ensemble puisque
ce sont deux monnaies qui ne sont qu'un
parfaitement convertibles ensemble et
qui et qui sont fabriqués en France ou
pas l'ambiguïté c'est que c'est le même
acronyme mais ce n'est pas le même nom
ça n'est pas la même ça n'est pas ce
n'est pas du tout la même signification
et ça n'est pas non plus la même la même
monnaie vous ne pourrez pas échanger
c'est lié sont fabriqués en France par
la Banque de France mais ça ça n'a rien
à voir avec le la convention monétaire
entre la France et ses étapes pourquoi
parce qu'il y a énormément de pays qui
font fabriquer leur monnaie à l'étranger
il faut bien faire la distinction entre
émettre une monnaie c'est-à-dire
vendre un bout de papier au nom de la
confiance avec une valeur monétaire avec
une valeur d'échange et fabriquer ce
papier donc la Banque de France est
juste un fournisseur et beaucoup de pays
en Afrique par exemple utilisent
d'autres fournisseurs étrangers comme de
la rue qui est politique derrière la
fabrication de cette monnaie politique
il y a une vieille relation commerciale
mais c'est une pure relation commerciale
qui a tout moment peut peu changer
cette monnaie c'est ce qu'on ressent
quand on regarde ce documentaire est-ce
que c'est la réalité ou est-ce que le
documentaire a fait un zoom sur une
contestation qui finalement serait assez
minoritaire où est-ce qu'elle est réelle
je pense que la contestation est réelle
c'est à dire qu'il y a deux niveaux il y
a la contestation liée à la question
coloniale il y a la contestation liée à
la question clientèle et lorsqu'on voit
des économistes qui se prononcent sur la
question du franc CFA c'est parce ils
estiment qu'il est important de faire
évoluer la politique monétaire des États
africains de donner aux pays africains
qui utilisent cette monnaie davantage de
liberté d'action dans un contexte
continental où la totalité des autres
pays qui ont leur indépendance ont une
monnaie nationale donc je dirais un
débat sur la question de la souveraineté
monétaire du rapport également à la
question des banques qui sont celles qui
détiennent réellement la souveraineté et
de l'autre côté le fait que le français
est FA et assimilé à une monnaie
effectivement liée à l'histoire de la
colonisation c'est une monnaie coloniale
née pendant la colonisation qui a été
validée dans le contexte des accords de
coopération monétaires au moment des
indépendances et sur laquelle on attend
que les chefs d'État se prononcent de
manière plus claire en termes de rupture
d'une part parce que cette monnaie
assimilée à une monnaie liée aux élites
et que les peuples estiment qu'il ne
voit pas les retombées de cette
soi-disant bonne santé économique et
monétaire dont leur quotidien donc du
coup des contestations populaires sont
totalement fondées elles sont légitimes
et elles s'inscrivent aussi dans une
évolution de la sociologie africaine les
populations africaines de 2023 ne sont
pas celles de 1960 ni celle de 1994
edrick Lam davantage je dirais de marge
d'action comptage je dirais leur prise
en main de leur destin économique et
donc à mon sens des contestations du
français sont fondées à la fois sur la
dimension coloniale et en même temps sur
la dimension clientèle qui peut être
effectivement de chercher d'autres
partenaires y compris pour l'impression
des billets qui peuvent proposer
d'autres conditions plus ou moins
avantageuses et il semble assez
insupportable ces françaisfa aux yeux
des Africains quand on regarde ce
documentaire Nicolas normand alors c'est
un documentaire à charge mais
malheureusement qui est distingue pas
bien la problématique du français enfin
parce que fondamentalement il y a deux
questions différentes et à la question
politique le relent de colonialisme
qu'incarme que symbolise le franc CFA
pour cette raison personnellement je
pense que le franc CFA est une erreur
pour la France d'avoir perpétué un
système qui est une boîte à fantasmes
d'une certaine manière parce que elle
aliment l'idée que la France dominerait
l'économie des pays de cette zone à
travers la monnaie mais c'est ignoré le
rôle de la monnaie j'y reviendrai après
en tout cas pour cette simple raison
psychologique politique il vaut mieux
couper les amarres et ne pas conserver
cette monnaie pour lever ses ambiguïtés
c'est important maintenant sur un plan
économique il se trouve que la zone de
Franc CFA les 14 pays concernés dont
d'ailleurs deux ne sont pas des
anciennes colonies françaises et
plusieurs anciennes colonies françaises
ne sont pas non plus dans la zone CFA
parce que chaque pays est libre de
sortir à tout moment c'est important
et de l'intégrer
dans les années 60 et revenu dans les
années 80 ils sont absolument libres de
le faire Madagascar a quitté la Guinée
n'est pas dans la zone franc la
Mauritanie n'est pas dans la zone franc
et une ancienne colonie espagnole la
Guinée équatoriale est dans la zone
franc une ancienne colonie portugaise a
demandé à aller dans la zone franc la
Guinée-Bissau maintenant sur le plan
économique qui se trouve que ces pays
qui sont dans la zone franc ont en
moyenne une meilleure croissance
économique que les pays qui sont hors
zone franc alors pourquoi en fait la
monnaie n'est pas déterminante dans la
croissance économique parce que la
croissance économique elle dépend pas
seulement de la politique monétaire il
faut qu'une monnaie soit stable donc
c'est une condition nécessaire mais pas
suffisante le franc CFA est une monnaie
stable il se trouve par exemple
ça remplit les trois rôles d'une monnaie
n'est-ce pas qui est de compter de payer
et de garder des réserves pour l'avenir
des réserves en valeur ça ça marche avec
le franc CFA maintenant le développement
économique ça dépend en fait du cadre
juridique ça dépend d'une politique
réglementaire des institutions et ça
dépend d'une politique budgétaire tout
ceci n'a rien à voir avec la politique
monétaire la politique monétaire c'est
garder une monnaie stable
essentiellement mais je vais vous donner
la parole Victorin lequel l'URL parce
que dans le film on entend des experts
parler d'une monnaie dont l'existence
même montre que le processus de
décolonisation n'est pas complètement
terminée je voudrais qu'on écoute cet
extrait de cet écrivain et économiste
sénégalais et je vous fais réagir juste
après
une histoire
et elle dit un lien avec la France avec
l'ex puissance rame coloniale qui n'a
pas été rompue c'est à dire que le
vestige que c'est la trace que c'est le
signe que c'est dit l'histoire d'une
décolonisation qui n'est pas achevée
est-ce que c'est franc CFA puisqu'il
faut parler de plusieurs Français façon
le symbole d'une décolonisation pas
complètement achevée on peut pas réviser
tout à fait ce qu'il dit puisque le
politique et les émotions ont pris le
pas sur l'économie et le monétaire ce
que vous disiez aujourd'hui la France a
perdu le combat politique et idéologique
parce que il y a une difficulté depuis
les années 60 d'ailleurs le franc CFA a
été créé officiellement 39 premier et
six sept en 1939 pour éviter les
conséquences de la guerre la fuite des
capitaux etc c'est après à 45
officiellement on crée ça
depuis lors et depuis les années
80-90 il y a une forte contestation
surtout auprès de la jeunesse qui n'est
pas forcément majoritaire parce que les
élites n'ont pas bougé les gouvernements
n'ont pas bougé d'accord
souvent militant et il y a pas vraiment
d'études d'économie appliquée pour
vérifier et ce qu'ils disent très
souvent on a des déclarations des
affirmations qui ne sont pas vérifiées
celui qui vous parle moi j'étais contre
Afrique de 17 vieux colonialisme etc je
le pense toujours il y a ce relent là
c'est récurrence là qui est là et c'est
vrai qu'il faut évoluer lorsqu'on a fait
le rapport on a écouté on a regardé les
ratio économiques on a regardant
l'économie comparative c'est beaucoup
plus nuancé que ça pourquoi parce que on
fait porter à la monnaie ce que vous
avez dit tout oh il y a au moins 98
indicateurs de développement économique
fait par le Forum économique mondial au
prix par le FMI et la Banque mondiale on
ne fait porter qu'à la seule monnaie à
la politique économique et à la
politique monétaire tout le reste par
exemple
c'est vrai qu'il faut rompre certains
nombre de choses on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir mais c'est vrai lorsque vous
donnez une parité fixe ça les avantages
ça a des inconvénients
à l'euro donc en créé à l'euro on peut
comprendre lorsqu'il y a une garantie de
convertibilité
inconditionnelle
il faut une contrepartie
des réserves la centralisation des
réserves à la Banque de France lorsque
vous avez une garantie de change on
évoque pas ça souvent si l'euro
s'apprécie ou se déprécie il y a une
compensation qui qui se fait bon oui
vous avez le la difficulté même si c'est
technique de l'incompatibilité de trois
objectifs avoir la stabilité
macroéconomique la stabilité des prix
faire dans le développement économique
et assurer la liberté de transaction et
de qualité symbolique c'était compatible
c'est trois objectifs là il faut
éliminer au moins 1 pour atteindre les
deux autres et ce que l'Afrique de
l'Ouest a fait ce que l'Afrique centrale
a fait et aussi les Comores même si la
parité est différente c'est de dire que
on va prioriser un objectif premier il y
a des objectifs secondaires c'est de
dire c'est la stabilité des prix et que
ça devrait profiter aux populations en
train de parler des avantages et des
inconvers yhabara j'ai trouvé cette
phrase d'un économiste récemment
interrogée dans un quotidien malien Mali
24 il s'appelle Modibo Mao et il nous
dit le franc CFA comporte des avantages
comme des inconvénients si vous voyez la
crise mondiale que nous venons de vivre
parlons celle que nous vivons en ce
moment les pays du franc CFA sont les
pays qui ont connu la plus faible
inflation et ont moins connu la crise
économique que tous les autres États en
Afrique d'abord est-ce que c'est vrai
est-ce que c'est faux est-ce que c'est
pas un argument qui vient aussi
contrebalancer cette colère contre ce
Français enfin très symbolique de la
colonisation
je pense que limiter la question du
franc CFA la stabilité ou la maîtrise de
l'inflation nous fait peut-être pas si à
côté de choses peut-être plus
essentielles je pense que l'inflation
n'est pas forcément le signe d'une bonne
santé économique il y a des pays qui ont
des taux d'inflation plus élevés mais
qui se développent qui ont une
croissance je pense que l'un des
éléments comme le ghanaï effectivement
donc l'un des éléments qui est
réellement souligné dans la question du
franc CFA c'est l'abolition de ce
système là pour permettre
de poser toutes les cartes sur la table
et de décider de la ligne politique
économique et monétaire qu'il souhaite
suivre donc il y a je pense un argument
quoi c'est ce que vous voulez c'est pas
un argument c'est un constat qui peut
être
Nicolas
la question psychologique et la question
politique est beaucoup plus importante
que la question technique c'est comme ça
c'est la réalité le monde fonctionne
ainsi voilà c'est mais oui absolument si
les gens rejettent un système c'est pour
des raisons politiques c'est pas
fondamentalement pour des raisons
techniques il se trouve sur des réseaux
pour des raisons techniques comme je le
disais tout à l'heure la zone CFA a eu
en moyenne une meilleure croissance que
la zone hors CFA et si vous prenez par
exemple l'Afrique de l'Ouest la Côte
d'Ivoire a le plus fort taux de
croissance de la région avec le franc
CFA ou malgré le franc CFA comme vous
voudrez et le Ghana a une inflation
énorme est en cessation de paiement ne
peut plus payer sa dette étant crise
économique le Nigéria aussi donc voilà
et puis pendant la crise du covid
n'est-ce pas en moyenne américaine il y
a une régression économique de
1,7%, sauf la zone franc ou c'était plus
0,3% c'est-à-dire on a gardé une petite
croissance en zone franc parce que les
deux banques centrales ont une politique
un peu accommodante une politique
monétaire racomodo plus de liquidités et
qui permettait de garder une stabilité
externe et de garder la stabilité
interne en matière de prix alors ce que
vous dites vous avez raison mais c'est
une décision politique comment faire
avec un régime de taux de change fixe et
de parité fixe pour impulser une plus
forte croissance plus d'emploi comment
le faire c'est tout le sujet et c'est le
problème de toutes les banques centrales
la Banque centrale européenne a le même
problème comment concilier l'emploi la
lutte contre l'inflation et la stabilité
macroéconomique c'est tout le sujet ça
c'est une décision politique que les
décideurs africains doivent prendre de
83 il part de l'écho 83 nous sommes en
2023 et depuis déjà de très longues
années on parle de réformer la zone
franc c'est vrai qu'il faut
[Musique]
c'est une phrase que j'ai retenu qui
nous dit on ne peut pas renoncer ça
souveraineté monétaire sous prétexte
qu'on veut renforcer le commerce qui met
en balance le politique et le technique
justement non je crois que je crois que
c'est un faux débat parce que tout ce
débat est en fait faussé par le symbole
en fait ce système il est victime de ses
origines donc il y a un délit de faciès
sur ce système parce que il a pour
origine la période coloniale or
qu'est-ce que c'est aujourd'hui que ce
système c'est trois monnaies à nouveau
qui sont gérés par des institutions
indépendantes et souveraines qui ont
fait trois choix le premier choix c'est
celui d'avoir une parité fixe et cette
parité fixe par nature elle contraint la
politique monétaire parce que ça devient
l'objectif il faut maintenir cette
parité fixe beaucoup de pays ont fait le
choix de la parité fixe ou d'une parité
quasi fixe plus de la moitié des pays
en dehors de la zone franc on fait le
choix d'avoir une parité fixe donc ce
choix c'est le vrai débat est-ce que il
faut maintenir une fixité est-ce que
d'abord l'encre et la bonne est-ce que
c'est l'euro est-ce qu'il faut un panier
de monnaie est-ce qu'il faut le dollar
et je dirais que depuis le passage à
l'euro
cet ancre a plus de crédibilité parce
que c'est quand même une zone plus large
et qui est le premier partenaire
commercial de la plupart de ces de ces
pays donc ça c'est le premier choix le
deuxième choix qu'on fait ces pays c'est
en tout cas en Afrique de l'Ouest en
Afrique centrale de vivre dans une union
monétaire qui va aussi est irritée de la
période coloniale mais il faut pas et je
crois que dans le documentaire Lionel
zinsoule explique très bien il faut pas
jeter ça aussi au nom d'un délit de
faciès et au nom de l'origine de la zone
l'union monétaire c'est un choix et la
conjonction des deux je termine
là-dessus c'est quand même le grand
avantage de ce système c'est que quand
vous vous trouvez dans un des pays qui
est en crise profonde et longue et
durable comme le cas de la Centrafrique
comme le cas du Mali et bien la monnaie
est préservée imaginez le contrefactuel
aujourd'hui si le Mali avait sa propre
monnaie ou si la Centrafrique avait sa
propre monnaie et vivait pas dans une
union molaire avec une
monnaiefa en tout cas une histoire trop
lourde et pose trop de questions pour
être conservé il a été question
plusieurs fois de l'enterrer le film le
rappelle et notamment en décembre 2019
lorsque les présidents ivoiriens et
français à la sanwattara Emmanuel Macron
annonce la fin du franc CFA et l'arrivée
d'une autre monnaie l'écho on aurait pu
alors se dire bah ça y est le problème
est réglé mais non pas d'après le
sociologue et économiste camerounais
martial zebelinda dans le film écoutez
on n'a pas résolu un problème on a créé
un nouveau puisqu'on a déjà un écho qui
existe qui a été accepté par 15 pays
africains et puis là on en a un autre
qui est décidé ou en tout cas
officialisé par le président français et
le président ivoirien et qui porte le
même nom
sur un périmètre relativement proche
donc 8 États
mais qui n'a pas le même concept
derrière
alors là pardonnez-moi on a besoin
d'explication l'écho existait déjà non
il existait en théorie c'est-à-dire on
s'était mis d'accord dans une conférence
pour le créer dans le futur voilà mais
il n'existait pas en pratique
parce que cette personne a tout à fait
raison dans le film il y a un problème
de méthode n'est-ce pas on a vu le
président français et le président
ivoirien tous les deux définir ce qu'il
fallait faire or ça concerne 14
ça concerne 14 pays donc si il fallait
la politique ne sont jamais bien loin
quand même le symbole et je voulais dire
plus important à la limite que la
technique parce que la technique c'est
une compétence qui devrait être laissée
au pays africain donc l'essentiel c'est
quand même le symbole que les pays
africains décident de même et que ce
soit pas l'ancienne puissance coloniale
qui interfèrent dans cette question
alors là on voit le président français
et le président ivoirien ensemble qui
annonce des réformes des décisions
importantes
il aurait fallu de toute évidence une
autre méthode il fallait réunir les 14
chefs d'État ensemble et qui discutent
des différentes options possibles et en
plus elle est évité de prendre le nom
écho parce que ça avait parce que ça
avait l'air de parasiter un projet qui
existait en dehors de la zone franc et
donc
s'appréhende et ça court-circuite la
réflexion du nigérienne le Nigéria le
Ghana qui était impliqué dans cette
discussion sur les coups on vient vous
décrypter avec nous ce moment les
documentaire parce que c'était pas clair
l'un des problèmes je pense c'est le
déni de démocratie qui est régulièrement
soulevé sur une question qui s'est quand
même imposée dans le débat public sur
laquelle on souhaitait que les
parlements nationaux africains soient
consultés qu'il y a de vrais débats pour
poser justement les choses clairement
sur la et qui aussi des campagnes de
pédagogie sur la question du franc CFA
ça n'a pas été le cas lors du discours
de Ouagadougou en 2017 Emmanuel Macron a
expliqué que c'est le problème des chefs
d'État africain deux ans plus tard il
doit lui-même se déplacer à Abidjan pour
annoncer la fin du franc CFA donc on
voit bien que sans la France rien ne
peut bouger et c'est d'autant plus
problématique d'un mot quelle
interprétation vous en faites est-ce que
c'est parce qu'il est face à des chefs
d'État africain peut-être pas d'accord
entre eux est-ce qu'il y a une
responsabilité du côté des dirigeants
africains ou pas non parce que d'une
part il le fait avec Alassane Ouattara
qui était quand même le plus grand
défenseur du français qui explique que
rien ne va changer avec l'écho en terme
de parité il le fait également dans le
cas d'une opération de communication où
il grille la politesse effectivement aux
autorités africaines et il le fait
également je dirais d'une certaine
manière assez assez problématique dans
le sens où il s'immix dans un autre
débat qui est celui de l'écho de la
CEDEAO et donc lorsqu'on demande à la
France de se retirer du franc CFA ou
d'abolir le franc CFA elle transforme ce
franc CFA sur un projet qui empiète sur
un autre projet ouest africain
cette approche est fondamentalement
coloniale puisqu'elle consiste
effectivement à larguer les amarres mais
à garder un filet qui permet de
récupérer tout ce qu'on a laissé de côté
et par ailleurs dont la suite des
conventions qui vont être signés on a un
maintien finalement de la plupart des
éléments puisque bon ce n'est pas demain
qu'on aura visiblement l'écoute donc un
changement cosmétique Bruno Gabriel
c'est sans doute maladroit parce que je
vois autour de la table que ça a été
voilà ça a été très très mal ressenti or
premièrement il s'agit d'un accord avec
les pays d'Afrique de l'Ouest et donc ça
marque bien ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est deux monnaies
indépendantes c'est pas la fin du franc
CFA c'est une réforme du franc CFA avec
ta formule entre la fonction
comprends plus rien c'est à dire donc
quand
le président Macron vient annoncé cela
avec Alassane Ouattara
il a mais du français d'Afrique de
l'Ouest c'est très important de le
comprendre c'est parce que à nouveau
parce que parce qu'il y a parce qu'il y
a deux monnaies deuxièmement c'est
l'aboutissement de négociation qui ont
été menées sur la base dure la
réaffirmation des choix qui avait été
fait par les pays de l'UEMOA
premièrement le choix d'un change fixe
deuxièmement le choix d'une garantie
française pour appuyer ce genre fixe et
troisièmement le choix de rester dans
une union monétaire que peut-être
d'autres pays vont rejoindre et pourquoi
le projet écho a du mal à se
matérialiser et bien parce que les deux
choix importants que j'avais signalé
tout à l'heure c'est à dire le choix
d'être dans une union monétaire avec le
Nigéria avec le Ghana etc c'est pas un
choix si facile que ça et que finalement
il y a des réticences de tous les côtés
pas seulement des anciens pays de
l'UEMOA mais du Nigéria qui l'a dit
lui-même et puis il y a des réticences
de cette union monétaire à faire l'autre
choix avoir une parité fixe vis-à-vis de
dollars ou de l'euro une ancre en tout
cas ou avoir un modèle de taux de change
flexible et là on a bien vu que le
président Ouattara lui était en faveur
du taux de change fixe parce que c'était
le système dans lequel vivent déjà les
pays de l'uemo il a déclaré à plusieurs
faux que reprise il a dit que l'écho le
grand éco si je puis dire devait
effectivement être un système un
changement fixe alors que non il
n'existe pas il n'existe pas il n'existe
pas parce que ces pays n'ont pas encore
accepté les conditions de ce choix un
être en union
et il n'existe pas les conditions posées
par le Nigéria c'est quand même le
retrait définitif de la France du
système de déco CFA y compris la
question de l'impression des meilleurs
en Afrique mais pourquoi mais pourquoi
il l'a dit c'est commercial c'est pas
monétaire ils peuvent changer hein
[Musique]
j'ai quand même cette question et je
vais la répéter y a-t-il une
responsabilité du côté des dirigeants
africains qui pas d'accord entre eux qui
complique la sortie du franc CFA ou pas
s'ils veulent changer rien ne les oblige
à rester dans l'union monétaire ou ils
peuvent changer pourquoi le change-t-il
parce qu'il y a des avantages parce
qu'il y a de la stabilité parce que
maintenant on arrive plus ou moins je
sais pas si c'est entre en vigueur parce
que la France a accepté de changer même
si on me dit que ça à la marge certains
disent cosmétiques il y a plus la
centralisation des réserves il y a
toujours une rémunération qui est des
ailes qui qui est octroyée mais
maintenant il y en aura plus donc il y
aura plus de il y a plus de réserves du
tout rien n'oblige les dirigeants
africains à rester dans une union qu'il
est qui serait
parce que moi ce que j'entends ce que je
vois et ce qu'on appelle entendre on
voit beaucoup de contestations notamment
d'une certaine jeunesse de militants qui
disent c'est identitaire c'est de la
souveraineté et c'est une géopolitique
des émotions et donc c'est vrai vous
avez raison le politique l'idéologie que
l'identité a pris le pas sur le
technique sur le monétaire et sur
lesquels
eux sont conscients que dans les
fluctuations monétaires dans demain
matin moi je propose un régime de chance
semi-flexible adoucir un panier de
monnaie ou peut-être DTS bon ça c'est à
voir mais c'est pas nous qui décidons ça
on a dit nous voilà recommandation
prudente c'est au dirigeants africains
de le faire c'est pas la France qui
empêche ils peuvent entrer et sortir
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt de la prudence
et et on nous lentement parce que
quelque part au-delà des opinions
publiques et des expressions publiques
il y a des avantages qu'ils ne veulent
pas abandonner dans le film l'État
français est accusé de garder une partie
de l'Afrique sous tutelle avec ce franc
CFA on va réécouter un intervenant nous
dire que la monnaie est la base de pour
dominer une économie mais on se
demandera ensuite si d'autres pays ne
sont pas en train de se servir de
l'Afrique sans passer par la monnaie je
pense à la façon dont la Chine est en
train de s'implanter économiquement ou
même à la Russie qui devient un
partenaire économique prioritaire pour
le Burkina Faso on en a entendu parler
ces derniers jours avant d'en parler
avec vous on va écouter la définition de
l'entreprise coloniale par cette
économiste et sciiste sénégalais dans le
film
l'entreprise coloniale en évacuant la
dimension monétaire parce qu'elle est
capitale parce que celui qui contrôle la
monnaie contre la production contrôle
l'échange contre la consommation
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas la
Chine et la Russie avec d'autres
méthodes avec une d'autres intentions
peut-être plus business mais en tout cas
qui sont là de coloniser une partie de
l'Afrique aussi alors je dirais pas de
coloniser en tout cas si c'est certain
que sur le plan commercial la Chine est
très présente et les prises partout dans
le monde la Russie je pense que c'est
quand même beaucoup beaucoup plus limité
qu'elle est quand même loin derrière les
intérêts français en Afrique
la Turquie oui de Maroc ou d'autres
acteurs il y a aussi l'apparition de
banque et de groupements panafricains
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui on a
d'autres alternatives qui s'offrent qui
sont peut-être plus avantageux que les
avantages qu'on aurait avec la France et
qui justement nécessite d'avoir ce débat
là je pense que c'est pas passé d'une
tutelle à une autre
il s'agit tout simplement de décider
quelle est la bonne ligne la bonne
politique monétaire budgétaire
économique financière pour permettre aux
pays africains de répondre aux attentes
des populations et je pense que les
dirigeants africains aujourd'hui ne sont
pas en phase avec les demandes des
revendications populaires et que plus on
avancera plus on aura des contestations
populaires qui amèneront les dirigeants
à prendre d'autres positions ou d'autres
dirigeants à se positionner davantage
sur ces questions Nicolas normand
certains pays d'Afrique souhaitent un
arrivage du CFA je l'ai lu dans des
articles Yohan ou roubles comment
faut-il voir cette implantation
économique rampante tranquille de la
Chine et de la Russie sur ses états
africains qui sont très liés à la France
on vient de le voir c'est peut-être pas
une très bonne idée parce que la Russie
a le poids de l'Espagne à peu près sur
le plan économique l'espace c'est un
nain économique quand même et si c'est
le choix des populations des États
concernés on peut choisir ce qu'ils
veulent oui mais ils sont tout à fait
libres écoutés par définition
c'est plus simple pour les pays
européens de la zone euro de faire du
commerce dans la devise euro c'est sûr
mais s'il faut passer par une autre
devise qui a un taux de change fixe ou
non c'est possible aussi ça ne va pas
arrêter le commerce voilà personne ne
voit ça c'est un aspect technique ça va
pas changer il y a pas de tutelle
française ni chinoise ni russe sur les
pays ils sont fondamentalement
souverains et ils choisissent leur
partenaires
les autres pays qui travaillent en
Afrique peuvent bénéficier de la
renversibilité de la crédibilité de la
zone aujourd'hui la France Garantie la
France peut convertir la France bon
quand la Chine exporte il y a une
stabilité de change et donc quelque part
et c'est la raison pour laquelle vous
entendez des gens dis non ça profite aux
entreprises françaises c'était peut-être
vous voyez il y a quelques longues
années parce que il y a une proximité
culturelle mais aujourd'hui c'est pas
tout à fait ça lorsque vous exportez
vous avez une assurance que vous aurez
en devise
des devises garanties donc alors la
question posée c'est l'éternel
discussion technique la neutralité de la
monnaie ça ne s'est raconté que non
c'est plus et je suis d'accord avec ça
c'est quand même un instrument
d'identité de souveraineté etc et la
monnaie joue un rôle considérable c'est
pas moi qui ai dit ça c'est pas à mon
avis
c'est pas crédible du point de vue c'est
pas crédible
passe par le dollar c'est une zone quand
même le groupe sincèrement je pense pas
que ce soit très sérieux du monde de la
crédibilité économique en revanche vous
avez l'euro qui est une monnaie crédible
vous avez euh
sérieux ce que aujourd'hui à mon sens
c'est en économiste je pourrais faire
les dirigeants africains pour mieux
répondre à leur opinion publique c'est
de dire puisque on a fait le compte sur
euh
économique sur l'emploi sur le pouvoir
d'achat des gens et bien on veut faire
plus de croissance plus d'employés
nationale moi c'est pas tout à fait ma
recommandation de dire comment peut-on
desserrer les rigidités comment peut-on
desserrer les contraintes
là il y a peut-être un régime adossé un
panier de Noël oui ce qui a demandé si
la liberté monétaire la liberté
monétaire veut pas dire qu'on va faire
n'importe quoi ou tout ce qu'on veut
avec la monnaie pour moi on peut décider
on peut décider de prendre une direction
et c'est ça qui est actuellement demandé
un problème de confiance vous pensez il
peut y avoir un problème de confiance
oui en fonction des dirigeants qui
justement fin de la politique budgétaire
de ces dirigeants là donc il y a
également la question de la corruption
qui est présente donc tous ces éléments
là sont à son analysés effectivement bon
je crois qu'à nouveau le symbole
politique fausse complètement le débat
parce que ce qui est important dans une
monnaie c'est la confiance la confiance
qu'elle inspire aux gens qui s'en
servent mais aussi aux gens de
l'extérieur donc c'est ça le phénomène
important il y a pas
la notion de souveraineté monétaire par
exemple nous en France nous avons
abandonné notre souveraineté monétaire
pour rentrer dans une union monétaire
qui a une crédibilité et qui a une
crédibilité forte parce justement les
politiques ont abandonné leur
souveraineté au profit d'une institution
indépendante qui a un mandat
sont des choix démocratiques que ça soit
un choix démocratique c'est tout à fait
important mais par contre ce qui est
important c'est de regarder l'efficacité
hors l'efficacité à lié à quoi elle est
liée dans la confiance parce que la
monnaie c'est à la base de la monnaie
c'est la confiance parce que sinon vous
prendriez pas un bout de papier qui vaut
l'équivalent
d'une d'une tête de bétail ou de deux
têtes de bétail c'est c'est ça qui est
important et donc c'est ça qui est qu'il
faut créer et donc que tout ce débat
soit
mais la souveraineté monétaire elle
existe elle existe déjà les
gouvernements en place sont libres de
quitter de quitter
pourquoi pas
économies russes et chinoises
à condition que ça crée de la confiance
et ce qui est important c'est que aussi
et c'est une dernière chose que je
voulais dire l'union monétaire donne
c'est vrai en zone euro c'est vrai dans
les pays de l'uemo et dans la C-Max plus
d'indépendance aux banques centrales et
donner plus d'indépendance au monde
centrale ces données plus de confiance
dans la monnaie parce que évidemment les
politiques sont toujours tentés et c'est
ça le danger de la souveraineté
monétaire les politiques sont toujours
tentés de manipuler la monnaie mais
l'essentiel n'est pas ce discours
technique qui est absolument vrai c'est
important qu'une monnaie fonctionne
sinon il y a des conséquences très
néfastes sur l'économie mais ce qui est
important aussi c'est la perception
populaire n'est-ce pas il y a un
traumatisme dû à la colonisation qu'il
faut pleinement prendre en compte or le
système franc CFA ne prend pas en compte
le traumatisme colonial et ça c'est un
péché je pense pas c'est une faute grave
à laquelle il faut remédier on se
dégageant de ce système alors on s'est
dégagé un peu sur le plan technique
puisque les réserves ne sont plus
stockées à la Banque de France mais
personne n'a communiqué là-dessus
mais personne ne le sait donc c'est déjà
effectivement une souveraineté
transférée mais personne ne le sait
parce qu'on a gardé
on n'a pas expliqué parce qu'on a pas
clairement coupé les amas on est resté
dans une ambiguïté je pense que
effectivement ça les amarres n'ont pas
été coupées on a gardé vraiment un filet
qui permet de repêcher la question du
fonciera donc pour moi le problème est
toujours présent il y a une dimension
coloniale dans cette monnaie il y a un
travail à faire pour permettre aux
Africains et pour laisser les Africains
accéder à leur souveraineté monétaire et
c'est un travail qui prend du temps et
je pense que les mesures qui ont été
prises sont des mesures faites dans la
précipitation qui créent beaucoup plus
d'ambiguïté que de clarté et qui sont
quelque part des tours de passe-passe
puisque tout ce qui a été aboli par la
réforme a été récupéré par d'autres
moyens donc pour moi on est dans un
statu quoonial et ce sera le mot de la
fin merci infiniment à tous les quatre
de
et merci de nous avoir éclairé sur un
sujet complexe et sur un documentaire
qui abordait un sujet difficile merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis on se retrouve très
vite sur Public Sénat à bientôt
[Musique]